welcome back to New rockstars I'm Hector
Navarro and is Kamala Khan now
officially a mutant in the comics we
know the Marvel Cinematic Universe
re-categorized the character as a mutant
in Ms Marvel but ahead of the
character's return in the Marvels
they're definitely cooking something up
by having Iman villani come over to
write these comic story lines I'm gonna
break all of this down for you because
what's happening with Ms Marvel in the
comics right now is potentially a bigger
deal than anything happening in the
movies and shows please subscribe to all
three channels in the new rockstars
Network this main channel the break room
and the Deep dive let's get started so
before bringing you up to speed on the
current kamalakon Comics condition we've
gotta back up just a bit and refresh you
on what's been happening to Ms Marvel in
reality 616. namely her death yep she
died sort of released at the end of May
of this year in issue number 26 of the
sixth volume of the long-running comic
series restarted in 2022 The Amazing
Spider-Man fan favorite character Kamala
Khan died you can read the entire 26
issue series to get all the specifics of
how it went down in case you want to
read it on your own but basically Kamala
dies the way most superheroes do saving
a life and saving the universe too a
villain from another dimension was after
Mary Jane Watson and would destroy the
universe if he were to murder her and
after an epic fight involving Spider-Man
fending off the villain and the bad guy
summoning a giant monster a few more
Heroes were brought into the action the
Fantastic Four a reformed Norman Osborne
flying around as the gold Goblin and Ms
Marvel were all helping Spider-Man by
dealing with the monster and trying to
keep MJ safe from the villain Kamala
Khan had been interning at Oscorp for
six months probably keeping an eye on
Osborne to see if he really was reformed
or if he would return to his Green
Goblin he ways as Ms Marvel carried MJ
away to safety we see that they split up
to try and lose the pursuing bad guy and
then the comic pulls a fake out making
us think the bad guy caught up to MJ and
stabbed her through the chest only it
wasn't MJ it was Kamala Khan using her
are shape-shifting abilities that she
has in the comics disguising herself as
MJ and thwarting the villain's evil plan
Peter Parker had been building a closer
friendship with Kamala since she started
her internship at Oscorp working for him
since he also worked at Oscorp Peter
arrives on the scene as she's dying and
they reveal their superhero identities
to one another Kamala passes away in
Spider-Man's arms tragically before
finishing her famous inspirational
catchphrase good is not a thing you are
it's a thing you you what a gut punch of
an ending and that ending was leaked
online two weeks early which forced
Marvel Comics to announce that Kamala
was dying and that her heroic Legacy
would be celebrated in another comic
called Fallen Friend the death of Ms
Marvel the leak coupled with the way the
story unfolded generated some
controversy for Comic readers and I'm
sure non-comic readers alike I will say
the art in The Amazing Spider-Man number
26 by the living legend John romita Jr
my favorite comic book artist of all
time was fantastic so after Ms Marvel's
death in may we we got a special
celebration of the character in July
with Fallen Friend the death of Ms
Marvel number one with some of the
characters original creators coming back
to contribute to it g Willow Wilson
wrote a story and Adrian alfona gifted
us with a beautiful variant cover the
issue features a few different story
segments starting with one showing us
The Supporting Cast of Ms Marvel Comics
like her sister Nakia her friends Bruno
and Zoe and her parents gathered in
their mosque to remember the Fallen
superhero Ms Marvel as well as the
innocent bystander lives lost in the
recent tragedy including Kamala Khan who
some don't know was secretly Ms Marvel
Logan AKA Wolverine appears and
introduces himself to kamala's Father
then red dagger kamala's potential love
interest shows up too followed by
kamala's favorite hero Carol Danvers AKA
Captain Marvel we also see the team of
young Heroes Ms Marvel was a part of the
Champions arriving to pay respects
Avengers like Captain America Sam Wilson
Iron Man Tony Stark and Dr Steven
strange were all present Steve Rogers
Captain America asks Sheikh Abdullah for
permission to say a few words finally
Peter Parker arrives late because of
course he does because it's typical
Parker lateness just in time to
introduce himself to kamala's parents
and tell them she was his hero close
personal friend of Eric Voss actor Iman
villani even popped into a comic store
Heroes World in Ontario Canada where she
grew up and bought her first ever Ms
Marvel comic to pick up this Fallen
Friend issue with that gorgeous Adrian
alfana cover phew now that I've caught
you all up to kamala's recent story we
can get into her upcoming rebirth and
new series Ms Marvel the new Mutant is a
four issue series launching next month
in August and Aman villani is going to
be co-writing the series with sabir
perzada who worked on the Moon Knight
and Miss Marvel shows and who also wrote
the Ms Marvel limited comic series that
was a part of the dark web event in the
comics Inhumans are mutated human beings
that have latent alien Cree DNA that
gives them superhuman abilities some
Savvy comic book fans have been
speculating that a change like this
might occur to Kamala Khan since the
live-action adaptation established that
Kamala was a mutant and not an inhuman
like she is in the comics Universe this
is because Marvel probably doesn't want
to throw off potential new readers too
much if they decide to head to their
local comic shop and check out their
favorite Marvel hero but have no fear
because if there's one thing we know
about Amman vilani it's that she's a
massive fan of the Marvel Comics
Universe even to the point where she
stands her ground against Kevin feige
and refers to the movie universe as
reality19999 as opposed to 616 which
Iman reserves for the original comic
Universe designation we stand a nerdy
Queen heck even across the spider versus
Miguel O'Hara agrees with her don't even
get me started on Doctor Strange and a
little nerd back on Earth 1999.99 editor
and producer and co-creator of the
character Sana Amina also revealed at
San Diego Comic-Con that Iman villani
would just show up to set with a crazy
book of ideas and that she quote knows
more than most people about Marvel
Comics history and we know that's true
it was amanat's idea to have villani
write a comic and Amman was hesitant
asking is anyone gonna let me and Sana
was like yeah Sana amanat also described
the process saying that sabir prasada
who again worked in the writer's room of
the Ms Marvel show shout out to writers
has really been guiding her through the
process and helping her hone in on the
millions of crazy ideas that she has so
knowing that Iman is such a Comics fan
and knows the history of this character
who debuted back in 2014. what did she
have to say about her now being revealed
as a mute Amman told Entertainment
Weekly quote I want to make it very very
clear that we are not retconning for
inhuman origin that's a part of kamala's
identity that Marvel editorial and
myself would very much like to keep and
protect our book will absolutely reflect
all those core themes of identity that
the Miss Marvel Comics have consistently
explored only now there's a whole new
label that Kamala has to learn to accept
it's gonna be pretty crazy Sana amanat
has talked about how it was always their
original intention to make Ms Marvel a
mutant and now she is in addition to
still being an inhuman and there of
course have already been mutant in human
hybrids in Marvel Comics like Daisy
Johnson AKA Quake Luna maximoff the
daughter of mutant Quicksilver and
inhuman Crystal and lunella Lafayette
AKA Moon girl but how is Kamala coming
back to life if you've been following
X-Men comics for a few years you may
already know that our favorite mutants
have basically mastered death Itself by
using their advanced technology and
knowledge to create Resurrection pods on
the island nation of krakowa itself a
sentient living being who is also a
mutant anyone who is a mutant and is
killed or dies can come back on krakowa
and live again and it's made for some
really interesting X-Men Centric stories
so we've learned that you can actually
read kamala's Resurrection confirming
that she's a mutant as well as being an
inhuman in X-Men Hellfire Gala 2023
number one which kicks off the new
storyline called ball of X out at the
end of July now there's already a bit of
controversy with this Hellfire Gala
comic with the way Kamala herself is
depicted fans have pointed out that the
art seems to show Kamala with a smaller
daintier nose maybe a bit too far off
from how she's normally depicted and
after her Resurrection which all mutant
characters emerge from krakowan eggs
naked and then are given clothes Kamala
is wearing a robe and showing her skin
even though the character is Muslim and
has been depicted as dressing more
modestly these sorts of details may get
lost or forgotten when producing monthly
Comics but fans have reminded everyone
that it's these details that sets Kamala
Khan apart from the majority of other
superhero characters and that it would
benefit Marvel to check with Muslim
writers and artists when portraying
Kamala in any medium over the San Diego
Comic-Con weekend we got a little bit
more information about the Ms Marvel the
new Mutant tour issue limited series
including the full reveal of the covers
for the first three issues Carlos Gomez
and Adam Gorham are going to be doing
the art for the the series and Sarah
pacelli is going to be doing the main
covers not only is Kamala back but she's
accepting a role as an X-Man and wearing
a new X uniform designed by Superstar
artist Jamie McKelvey who redesigned
Carol danvers's costume when she took on
the mantle of Captain Marvel and also
kamala's first iconic costume when she
became Ms Marvel and Jamie McKelvey the
artist who Iman villani is a huge fan of
in fact co-writer sabir prasada says
working with Iman was quote actually a
very humbling experience because she
knows her comics even better than I do
and that is saying something she was
throwing out references to specific
Comics that came out before either of us
were born she has a very great eye for
what makes a good sequence on the page
as drawn by an artist it was very
impressive to me to see her throw out
all these references to different
artists that she's been following
through the years now this may be only a
four issue series but Marvel Comics fans
are extremely excited and cheering for
Aman villani to crush it she said to
Entertainment Weekly this was way
scarier than joining the MCU for me
those projects feel like they live in
their own Dimension so I guess I can
separate myself easier but you can hold
a comic book I've never written anything
before in my entire life but I have read
many Comics so I just wrote what I would
want to read I was given a very
professional tool to write what is
essentially my own fan fiction it's so
awesome to be able to contribute to the
official Marvel Comics Canon Emon I
think you're a bit more qualified than
you're giving yourself credit for and I
hope that you enjoy the process so much
you can come back and write more and
more eventually exhausting that crazy
book of ideas now it's not too common
for a comic series to get its own
trailer so this must mean Marvel Comics
is really happy with the final product I
think many comic fans already knew this
even after we learned about kamala's
death but it looks like Miss Marvel's
future the Marvel 616 is bright and
beautiful and if you haven't yet
experienced the joy of reading Miss
Marvel Comics this new four issue series
seems like the perfect jumping on point
but if you want to go back to the
beginning I can't recommend a better
collection than Ms Marvel Kamala Khan
which collects her first 11 issues and
some extras thank you so much for
watching don't forget to subscribe to
all three of our channels check out the
awesome nerd Riot merch go pre-order Ms
Marvel the new Mutant at your local
Friendly comic book store today see ya
[Music]